well the White House has declined the
invitation from Democrats to participate
in the next public impeachment hearing
which is set for Monday the president
and his legal teams decision to sit out
the next round of questioning comes as
Democrats on the House Judiciary
Committee are set to spend the weekend
drafting articles of impeachment
Natalie bran is at the White House
Natalie good morning really no surprise
here good morning Michele no surprise in
the White House already preparing for a
possible trial in the Senate as House
Democrats have set the stage for a
possible full vote before Christmas now
the president on camera Friday avoided
talking impeachment instead taking
advantage of that good economic news a
record 158 million Americans are now
working that's the largest number in the
history of our country
president Trump touted the latest jobs
numbers while letting his White House
Counsel addressed the next steps toward
impeachment the president's legal
council rejected House Judiciary
Chairman Jerry Nadler Zinn vut ation to
participate in Monday's upcoming hearing
in an angry letter path Cipollone II
wrote adopting articles of impeachment
would be a reckless abuse of power by
House Democrats and would constitute the
most unjust highly partisan attempt at
impeachment House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
argues it's the president who's abused
his office for his own personal
political benefit our democracy is what
is at stake the president leaves us no
choice but to act because he is trying
to corrupt once again the election for
his own benefit the House Judiciary
Committee will work through the weekend
on track to draft articles of
impeachment as soon as next week
but there's debate among Democrats about
whether to keep charges limited to the
president's dealings with Ukraine or to
broaden them to include conduct
investigated in the Moller report
believe he gave at least 10 or 11
instances where the president clearly
crossed the line with respect to
obstruction justice to ignore that
history
precedent that is most unwelcome so my
advice has been keep it focused keep it
simple now the top Republican on House
Judiciary sent this letter to chair
Nadler Friday night detailing the
witnesses he'd like to hear from
including intelligence chair Adam Schick
the whistleblower hunter Biden
ultimately Democrats on that committee
have the final say over who testifies
control the process now in response to
the White House not participating on
Monday chair Nadler says having declined
the opportunity the president cannot
claim the process is unfair Jeff okay
Natalie thank you very much